by a vote of 6 to 0
Joey you are evicted from the Big
Brother house I appreciate it all right
Joey
no sad to see here I'm not you're not
happy to be here very happy why are you
happy
I'm just happy it was a great ride and
you know my journey was to be a part of
this crazy family and my journey is you
know to be moving on at this point so
I'm celebrating all of it celebrating
all of it it was unanimous vote - you
out absolutely what does that a surprise
at all not at all
no when did you know you were gonna be
out all right pretty much as soon as
Jonathan and Ryan went out because the
house deemed the three of us is you know
huge threats which is a compliment you
know you have to take that as a
compliment so even though it's kind of
funny because physicality really has
nothing to do with a lot of those
challenges obviously it's luck and
chance and just some crazy skill set
that you may not even know you have so
but yeah it's it's all good you know the
house was divided very quickly I didn't
even really know what was happening
before you know Jonathan was blown out
and then Ryan was blown out I thought
hmm I was a betting man which I'm not
but if I was I would guess my car to be
next despite all the tears and the pleas
that you saw yeah like I kind of felt it
coming so I was wearing a nice girdle so
the knife didn't go all the way through
so I'm gonna recover quickly thank you
in case anyone's wondering yeah cuz we
saw you try and kind of rope Natalie and
Lolo into getting you to stay it seemed
well what I was doing was I looked
there's an energy in the house you know
Tom and Cato thought they had the whole
place on lockdown not only that but in
like the way that was growing men were
going about it with intimidation and
being mean and just wasn't the right way
to do it they're like grown men and it
was just weird so I went in and said hey
look guys whatever happens get the best
energy to the final week because that
way America and if I'm home we can enjoy
watching the game being played the right
way not scare tactics or intimidation
which is just it's not it's not right
you know so that's what I was doing and
it turned into a conversation where they
were like hey maybe you're part of that
I said great if I'm part of it awesome I
you know that'd be fun and if not then
get me out of here if you deem me a
threat and you know it'll be fun to
watch you guys all cannibalize on each
other which is what's gonna happen
I wasn't there you didn't go home and
watch the rest of the season and watch
how this all plays out of course of
course I have to be back here to the
finale you know what I'm talking about
which I didn't know before I signed up
so hopefully I'll feel a little more you
know a little more savvy with my
critique I came back are you gonna go
back and watch all the episodes that
have aired so far and see how you did at
some point okay I hate analyzing myself
you know it's that's why this was very
out-of-body for me I told you you know
and my daughters were like daddy please
do it when I was talking to my family
about it and because they've never
really been able to watch any of my
stuff cuz they were really young when I
was doing Melissa and Joey and just to
mature and write all the other stuff was
way too mature so they never really seen
me like currently on TV even Hawaii
five-o stuff was just it was too much so
you know I got sucked into it I was like
alright I'll do what she can watch me on
TV it's not what I do I'm not a reality
guy I have much respect for people who
do this for a living like the reality
stuff because it's not my cup of tea I
don't mind watching dailies myself but
you know playing characters but this is
not me at all ya gotta be yourself
well I'm cool with that I just I I just
living with 12 other people that I don't
know that's that's the part myself is
fine but you know III predict what I'm
gonna do
these people they yeah it's amazing yeah
who would you say is running that house
right now who's really in charge I would
say probably Tamar is running that house
right now okay yes and I saw that at the
end because she was vacillating between
kandi who's her friends so no hard
feelings there she had to keep kandi I I
mean if it was between Tamar and Ryan I
would have kept Ryan you know so that's
just the game it was the smart game move
like in terms of giving yourself the
best chance to win competitions she
would have kept me because that's just
the way it works but she went with her
heart which happens a lot so you know I
even said at the end I said look use
your minds not your hearts knowing that
she was gonna go around hard yeah uh
speaking of Tamar there's a power up for
grabs this week yeah how are the
publicist she has it what do you think
of that what is the what does that mean
so that means thank goes for this
weekend for next week if she gets put on
the block she can take herself off nice
so she definitely is running the house
yeah no but I knew that look look Tamar
is a dominating person
you know she has a larger-than-life type
personality you know you very rarely see
kind of the other side to that I'm sure
there is another side but publicly for
whatever it's worth she likes that to be
her persona she's super loud she's super
emotional she's actually a super great
person too
but her energy is a lot to handle so it
can you can be overwhelmed easily not me
but everyone in that house is I don't
even think they realize how overwhelming
they are but they're overwhelmed to the
point where that group when it was up to
Tamar to decide between me and candy
they all went that way you know so
that's how much power she has right now
in that house I think you're gonna be
interested to see watching the episodes
back yeah because it's the way we're
seeing it on TV yeah Lolo and Natalie
are running this game right it's not
that's not what's happening but that may
be what you're seeing that's I was on
the inside got it that's what's going on
trust me I know I know what's going on
I've seen things you guys even haven't
seen yes and that's that's wild too but
I had to sign a lot of paper what
surprised you the most about this house
um just how how unraveled people become
quickly I mean everybody had an
explosion in there you know except like
Jonathan or Ryan I I think we're the
only three ones that were like haven't
gotten into it with somebody now Lolo
tried to sucker me into a moment you
know and then she was telling me be a
real man and I'm using all of my
breathing ability just breathe through
this this woman doesn't know what she's
talking about
you know but um but she tries to rob
everybody in she's she's uh she's a
hothead
you know nice person but hothead but but
I think it exposes your vulnerabilities
very very quickly and most the house is
you know expose them like instantly so
you know even to the point where the
jokesters in the house we're going nuts
so and you know they'll remain nameless
but they know who they are if you had to
call it right now yeah who wins this
game well look if I had to call it right
now I mean look I think Tamar thinks
she's gonna win you know but at the end
of the day what you have to keep in mind
is you have to also be likable
because there is a panel that will vote
for the final
- you know and depending on who's there
with her if it is her in somebody else
you know we're gonna go for the person
that was most consistent and most kind
and you know that comes into play a lot
at the end you know when you saw that
last season you saw play out Marissa had
the better track record and was
genuinely kinder in the house and that's
why she won so you know could be
interesting at the very at the very end
okay yeah there's still a lot of game
left so there's a lot of game but I'm
telling you being kind is very important
you lose sight of that with all the
backstabbing and backdooring and you
know everybody loves the manipulation I
hate that crap so it was very bad at it
you know I was even told like you know a
couple my friends like oh dude you got
you're hearing conversations go listen
to the door I'm like listen in the door
use a cup and Ryan actually did that
once and I found myself going like
they're talking hi I'm sick of my
stomach do I listen this is like you
know I heard two or three things and I
was like I can't listen anymore yeah but
the people manipulation and deceit comes
very easy to some people it's shocking
to see how easily it is for them to do
this very difficult for me so you know
like abilities huge we'll see how that
plays into the end that's the game it's
a game did you make any friends for life
in that house you know honestly for me
at this point in my life I've figured
out that genuineness and kindness are
the two most important things because
let's face when you get no relation with
somebody right whether it's boyfriend
girlfriend friend you know husband wife
you're not you're not you shouldn't be
getting into that relationship to change
them right you should be falling in love
or loving them for who they are because
you're not really gonna change anybody
right so that being said I think Ryan is
like one of the most genuine people I've
ever met no nobody's perfect God knows
I'm not but he is a kind genuine person
we truly hit it off spent most of time
talking about like bro stuff we didn't
even really talk we little games talk
but it was like 70/30 probably the wrong
way but but I I think he's fantastic so
we will definitely be hanging out and
I'm thankful for meeting him very cool
yeah now after this you are free you can
do out there what's the first thing
you're doing I'm going to just make a
call on my cell you know to like my
loved ones and tell them that I'm okay
and I'm gonna look at the sky because
unlike the summer show we
get to see sky right we have not seen
the sky in like 21 days to the point
where for the first time my life I was
like does anybody vitamin D because I
think it's you need to see some Sun like
it's the body needs it so it's crazy man
so I'm just gonna look up in the heavens
above and go thank you Lord for blessing
it was amazing sky and I'm going to call
my loved ones and like I you know I'm
very proud of the fact that my daughters
are almost 13 and 9 and this is the
first 21 days that I have not seen their
faces whether it's been either in person
or FaceTime so it's been very difficult
for me to deal with not seeing them
because I've never not seen them I've
always made it a point that'll be an
emotional reunion it's gonna be awesome
man happy yeah happy happy stuff we'll
let you go have that thank you man
Congrats on Matthew as far
I'm good time being free dude I'm so
thank you I'll take that one and I'm
doing watching the rest of the show from
home
[Music]